[Music]  knocked away by Williams curry long  three bingo  and the Gowanus take because usually  would say the visitors in there visiting  blues or what have ya  he's been an all-star but winning when  he was a starter so uh somebody hit it  past the back iron green go together  you're not gonna miss two in a row away  no curry and green vote back  introvert curry  seven o'clock three ball bobzilla p2p  Andre  and curry deandre town sanic can't  control it  nine seconds to go plenty of time for  this group and the cookies there that  although curry fish we  right hand not saying he can't go right  but little buddy and this is a date is  it's the third order hall  [Applause]